this is a story of a young man called
Ali and his journey and experiences
trials and tribulations an emotional
journey of rejection comments already
for this documentary okay so they're
dressed up in red you see those females
those nine females yeah in the neck up
and have it they're not sitting like
this listen like that before the video
starts guys check out sponsors and
natures blend they specialize in premium
Ethiopian black seed products their
products are fantastic health
supplements and also from the Sun now
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
Salam 10 for 10% of their products what
are you guys waiting for
Salam alaikum warahmatullah better care
to bothers and sisters and dear friends
welcome to my channel it's been a long
time since I've done a reaction video
I've been really busy really really busy
and hundred a you know been having a lot
of discussions in the park etcetera so
I've been heavily constraint on the raw
type of Dawa so after day I came across
Bravo excuse post about some girl called
French Montana heard of his name before
but I don't really know him and I don't
want to know him Israel to be honest so
forth French Montana's gonna step into
the scene doing some buki stuff then you
can't see another one Kurdish alley and
Egyptian Castello
so I come to steps into the scene to fix
up the French Montana yeah now so this
one Costello
so Marcus Tara is involved in the sheets
yes no I'm a spoken word spoken word
Nasheed's
production in production okay no bless
you in Charlotte for coming yes you have
a background now in the music industry
in the music industry to do with
composition production film scoring
music nor that but handle at the moment
we just doing the sheets okay mashallah
and with our editor ABS
now he has he's been inertia for my very
strong background in the music industry
he doesn't have been on camera so he's
not gonna much import right you see the
input in the merge documentary you'll
realize what his input is
he likes to show it not to KITT yeah so
okay so all gonna do is we're gonna go
straight into this video that's been
done and we're gonna analyze obviously
you check the lyrics yeah and I'm gonna
come from more of the visual and see
what why he's doing this
and good to be understanding he's Muslim
not yeah of course Nam he's Muslim or
Oconee Moroccan indeed yes okay all
right
so obviously there's gonna be no music
and so okay
I'm assuming they're not his wife's and
of course not yes he would like that
probably yeah
do you believe cigarettes are on me yeah
that's how I'm definitely for sure okay
okay we've already stopped in her on
please falling sisters okay okay I'm
gonna stop it here yeah okay so how many
females do yeah so I think this is it I
think it's the first ever music video of
a rapper now I'm reacting to but I can
react to okay yeah yeah that's good
there's no naked there's no naked girls
there's nothing like it
yeah so why obviously exactly so it
saves us heading of blurring everything
in there yeah and these these woman are
just covered up cover up now looking
from that angle obviously to us is just
like yeah you know there's no harm in it
yeah yeah I'm not gonna come and say you
know wearing reduce is haram but those
kind of red boots up to the knees as far
as I know certain women in a certain
industry well then yes I thought that if
I'm not mistaken here please correct me
yes
so we've got a bunch of naked woman 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 9 yeah now that's really
important cause you're gonna come from
aspects of some Illuminati stuff now you
know so numbers are very important in
these people very important so maybe
I'll just highlight that really maybe in
a favor but there's nine of them here so
now we need to also understand that in
today's society there's some madness
happening yeah so be it with the
transgender community for example or I
want to be identified as a penguin you
call me a penguin and I wanna be yeah I
feel 11 years old identify as 11 so this
freedom yeah
now with no limits its you can see the
fruits its bearing yeah the site is
going on on a manual like I said in many
videos there was a guy who married a
piano I'm sure he's happy because the
piano don't speak back yeah but that's a
different story
so right now I find this problematic
yeah because it's gives this weird
message people don't think to deeper by
but when I look at analyze a key it's
it's reminds me and I'll make it look
look I mean I make it very clear and
this we don't wanna be talking about in
depth detail about our sisters yeah and
stuff that they go through we're gonna
be talking about the haram police you
always have a go at them yes so have a
balanced approach yeah
I do just to balance that is what you
get it but here it's it's I don't know
it's me person it reminds me of sadly
our sisters and above this robot
specifically cuz they assist females in
here you know
sisters who may dress up wearing the
hijab but wear leggings and literally
you can see the shape of your body you
know in the fossil sternum said one of
the signs of their journey is a woman
that we close but naked and we
understand that today because if back
then they'll be thinking about how could
be one be clothed by naked you
understand it very clearly today we need
clear here you know be in whatever it
may be so I get this vibe where sexual
ization definitely and you said
something profound before about before
they would use naked girls and they've
kind of moved on from that
so what they need to do for the Shaitaan
does he would work very professionally
yeah the way he works he will target you
with your own people
yeah so he will send let's say I don't
know he will make a spy out of your own
family it will make it any man your own
family yeah
so you can relate to that person you can
trust them you can everything and
everybody looks at it also yeah I can
masha'Allah Egyptian Marshall another
what they're not looking at is what
they've actually done here
they've in the industry Illuminati and
everything they use they've used
everything naked women you know where
and you know whatever they wearing and
everything that they done that then they
used tuck Liddy which is a like a shabby
we call it an Arabic yeah so they're
done you know Moroccan shabby Egyptian
shabby then they mix your shabby is very
tradition like for example that will mix
that additional music how the truck the
tribals are the people with the tribes
and everything okay but what's here this
is like more Islamic mmm right here so
it's so what they're trying to do is
toggle switch our own woman here mmm
so now we have no club which we don't
have naked woman yeah we don't have to
ditional which is the you know wearing
today digital clothes and in here even
what did their traditional music now is
neck up yeah you don't even know if
there's a woman in the back one like
yeah
in today's society we don't even know
yeah exactly yeah so new pub with
different boots the red boots is there
definitely stuff to do with the
Illuminati em yeah Freemason mode of
nausea so they have you know there are
symbols and signs and what they do that
they get into your mind slowly so you
get used to it and adapt it to it you
know and that's the way they have very
strong tactics to to do all of this and
yeah okay is this kind of watching it's
kind of [ __ ] okay here we go and I say
what so what's next okay okay is that a
real person but can I just go back of it
is that that's not a real person well
that's not a real person but that's a
dummy
I don't even if you know monkeys like
that well that's not real person if I'm
a little person not anyway even if it's
a real person
they are looking quite fake definitely
okay but what's this what's this bubbles
well why they always do this trance
Campbell loser wins
Aloha simples and science yeah then you
know that they is a devotion like if yes
it's a devotion know that they have okay
yes she looks real
and what guys battling we're gonna come
to the lyrics brothers written some
stuff we're gonna go for the lyrics and
tried to go and analyze it a bit I just
want to watch a few more believe me
about 20 seconds yeah okay here hey this
is this is this is this word gets a
little bit interesting
not literally the songs over a days
using of the devil and then suicidal
okay I want to catch that right it was
okay one stop - here yeah so they're
dressed up in red yeah as far as I know
it's if it's Haram to dress something
for it yeah but that's the least of our
concerns right now I'm just trying to
make a point here so now the thing is
like what I see when I watch this
you see those females those nine females
yeah in the neck up and have it they're
not sitting like this listen like this
and that's like some kind of like a
female power kind of I'm in control kind
of movement going on do you get it yes
they're in the clubs
yeah it's like oppression yes but it's
like the only underneath like kind of I
see a attack towards the Miss Muslim
woman this.yc
and this has been carrying on even in
the porn industry yes I was going to be
a reaction video to a a porn actor who
came out and exposing this whole thing
yeah yes and you can see there's a
full-blown attack and with this picture
right here of this female aqui look I've
seen certain sisters who may be doing
stuff like there was one that I saw to
me I found it disturbing it was a sister
who was doing something for night yes
and I came across this picture and as
that like people in the Dawa we have to
analyze this and we have to do you can
say it's obviously it's not permissible
to look and I'm not looking anything I'm
seen the sister was clothed but naked
naked but she was sat in a very
provocative way which I can't even
demonstrate and she had her tongue out
and she was that like this yet it is my
sister so I figured me I know you guys
are probably cringing I cringe as well I
just have to make the imagination
understand so I see here when I see this
this is like you're a hijab' but you can
be out there you hear it you know you
don't need to be the norm you know and
there'll be a lot of feminist sisters
watching this and be like yeah you go
girl you know go get you some you know
all this kind of they get some they get
gas so when I see this okay I make
correlations gia I'm trying to see the
niqab is sitting like that for the fact
that he's using a cobby
is an outright attack on our sisters and
that
exactly what the Sharia came to protect
one of the things was lineage and the
punishment for adultery is so severe
yeah it's a deterrent yeah but the
reason why it's there is because they
came to preserve the lineage ya know and
what they doing now is they're attacking
that now okay this is very crucial this
is very important on bats a divorces are
on a mass level I've been hearing bone
left right center it's crazy
now this there's many factors that play
a role you get up and this is one of the
reasons why I'm doing my doc you
mentioned here and people see this
documentary are something that high
paying Gaussian cuz I want look like
well I it's the the plan the method that
we're coming through is to combat this
disease yes yes because what they're
doing is they're destroying the woman
and the woman and understand they see me
as a liberation unliberated here and you
have some people of influence yeah sadly
taking the hijab this happened last year
yes and I did a whole video about it I
don't if you sorry that given Muslim
girls my phone experiment other if you
haven't come across it I didn't come
okay so basically this happened last
year there's a group of young sisters in
the YouTube seen Instagram scene and
sadly this time machine or sometimes you
know I've heard this a lot will be I'm
not gonna give name certain Muslim
YouTube men females and males
yeah males as well they come and say I
want to be more of myself and any
features of what you mean you want to be
yourself it seems like they were going
through a phase of fakeness and they
thought this is too much
now what they mean by that is look this
is not really me I'm fed up of being
like this it's a burden on me I have to
tell you what I really am and then
sometimes I'm not seeing all sisters
taking their jobs off Brahmas in the
youtube scene start doing some madnesses
yes and you can see now I'll give myself
as an example yes I imagine to myself
and I say okay I'm in the Dawa if I
genuinely did not believe and done this
this is gonna be such a burden on me can
you imagine me to act on that assalamu
alaikum warahmatullah better care to
buffers and i'm in my real life I'm
doing the opposite I'd have to live a
double life be bipolar yeah Geum jandi
so for why I see from this Acura is I
don't even
I just need playing at that bar you can
see especially it comes back to the
hijab ego yeah
faith what is that like what what is
that luck are you what are you a zombie
like why are you giving that you know
that seductive face but the only thing
is like some kind of like why that this
rule is this you be I'm trying to say
only this redness is to do with Johanna
Murphy oh we know that that's what they
they say these people offer they worship
the D not the dinner you know of course
it bother you gonna night yeah yeah be
not yeah yeah v na dinner now what does
not mean agenda by Dean Aria so these
are the people of Joseon I mean yeah
they cool into that ya akhi what what do
you think you got Yanni it's very
disturbing man it's very very disturbing
I mean it's like this they want to use
the Shetlands number ones weapon was to
use the Shaitaan Shaitaan was number one
weapon was to use woman yes against men
yes and sadly he tried to use our mother
how we're against edematous and i'm
allah subhanaw taala
yeah need to us in the quran and
everything was shown to us and I had my
cinnamon how are they said I'm day you
know they eat a lot old stuff Allah for
lots of Panettiere the minister phone
and they were you know examples and you
know principles out there for us to
learn from but that's what they say Tom
wants he wants to what he wants to use
the woman all as weapons against our
families against our culture against our
Deen because when he does that he he
ruins everything that we have okay so a
feminist watching I they're gonna say oh
what are you trying to say a chance a
woman are the evil that they're using I
guess what are you trying to say brother
Costello are you try like I know a
conference just to clarify yeah you're
not seeing women are evil
no I was seeing that for example they
are using our sisters yeah they're using
our sisters because what's the biggest
weakness for a month
well the woman exactly so poetry in
Arabic was it so one someone said what
she was long to say he said in the
massage I obtained a Hadouken Alana well
there are Devils that have been created
for us that's what he says and it's very
wrong
when I Rudy will let him encourage
sayidina so I seek refuge in Allah from
ulta shayateen then the woman who was
she had more
ha Arabic she was proper strong
mashallah she said in the Nisa and I
hain't a Hellenic um the woman a flowers
made for you and everybody loves
smelling the fragrance of the flowers so
she was fitted yeah she she count them
she's so yeah hummed in love the woman
is what we're talking about this woman
is a very strong value on Islam and it's
it's we have to protect our honor and
dignity and you know because the woman
is a madrasah is a teacher for our
children and and you know a school and
if it goes the wrong way the kids that
will be misguided in the shape and
number one he sends his soldiers are
everyday to separate families yes and
this Disney stuff in soloq and you said
something you said protector or not
obviously me because we own a woman yeah
yes because you know some people I'm
just you know some people misconstrue
this or you're trying to say honor
killings you know there are or no
nothing to do to do what that is all
this or spiritually trust me a few
people watching I'm just clarifying
because I know what do you mean
especially so we honor our sisters in
our hands and they they are the
foundation because there was a thing of
a scholar he said a woman are half the
population of this earth and they give
birth to the other half course yeah so
the thing is like out like exams that
process and wife's extra we do not take
those as role models yes and sometimes
you seen the power of the documentary at
this like assemble this whole thing
because as men we play a big role yes I
call it the supply-demand change and
you've seen the documentary because as
men when we have expectations that's a
demand and there's gonna be supplied to
that yeah so we are as much to blame for
this kind of narrative this kind of
attitude that's been spread of you know
sisters wanted to look a certain way
going through lip fillings a key out of
the all kinds of stuff like wanna is
torture I believe is torture that the
you know is calm down toes but I should
go to the lyrics it was wait some stuff
he says so he was then he wasn't saying
much about there's a lot of hidden works
obviously that is very hard to
understand or it's a lot of play word
and so it's it's not easy to to break
through straightaway it's a new record
just came out two days ago and he needs
to be analyzed a little bit more better
yeah you know what what what what do you
think he's done this for why out of
everything about life well you see the
thing is it goes back to what I said in
the beginning Freemasons and Illuminati
yeah you know it was invented in the
1700s yeah and it was to keep the rich
rich whatever cost it is and the poor
poor and so there's either the rich or
the poor there's no middle class which
is us Islam made us you made us you no
one left for a bane arabiya monogamy
elaborate up what that doesn't exist in
them that's not they don't care you know
and their God is one there's no there's
there's other yeah it's the Shaitaan
Hollis you know they that's that song is
Lucifer so um they have to follow
certain which was and rules and for
example for him he needs to sacrifice
his own people yeah easy so they don't
want him to do what everybody else is
done look what everybody else does oh
yeah I say no so show naked women they
don't everybody does that but something
else that your people can relate to for
example and then they all get at that
they will adapt to it and it becomes
normal yeah just like you know like some
of the nursery songs that you know kids
sing and it becomes known yeah yeah yeah
that's that's what's happening man first
simply with an outright attack on the
family unit what Islam has come to
preserve and if I think that though I
think with them is like you know a
mission accomplished you know we've done
that you know like imagine they didn't
rap songs and they're calling the woman
a ho the corner the b-word and packing
julia will see these same goes in the
clubs singing along to it yes yeah I'm a
ho and they love it and I'm thinking
like and to me it just seems that you
know what though but that kind of type
is done it's time we knew that is I
don't wait in line for you know
subhanAllah sisters and I yeah yeah for
the woman like whatever whatever faith
day or whatever religion like this one
on a woman yeah yeah yeah it's actually
of course and people answered the owner
that they defend that and I think having
these naked because it's like it's
finished nice boring with the same oh
now it's like different now they're
going for our sisters they're gonna see
Italian for women but no were women
yes exactly as you get it so you can see
brothers and sisters and inshallah like
in the documentary we take you on a
journey and inshallah we inshallah our
whole aim is to nurture you guys to the
reality of what's gonna be the little
things that you watching you look up to
these people you have processes aside
brothers look up the dream was think
today's etc what like they are here to
destroy this mental that's the aim and
objective and this time with a family
unit and because the voices are so high
our whole object with the marriage
documentary is to sustain marriages as
well not just to find the person in a
Holloway to get married but also to
sustain so biography kami Allah bless
you each other I love him I really
really appreciate your insistence if you
can tell us something that we've missed
that you may have seen in the video
please elaborate further you know in the
comment section as well and we hope you
guys are benefited and if I'm not
mistaken brother Eskew is gonna be doing
a video about this as well hopefully if
he does I'll put the link days when I
shall take what she's important is well
i'm d'lai believe you and he it comes in
a good angle in certain aspects barack
Rafique Mian a bless you guys
assalamu alaikum wa hitori bear here too